Creating a full-length feature film is a monumental
task for any director.
In the storm of actors, set designs, production
assistants and the cameras catching them all,
the finished movie is just a tiny glimpse
of the actual work – and talented people
- that goes into making it.
Usually, it’s the editor’s job to make
sure that what’s outside of each shot stays
there – but they’re only human.
Which means some truly incredible mistakes
can make it into the final product for our
viewing pleasure.
Here are Screen Rant’s Movie Mistakes That
Slipped Through Editing.
The Bourne Identity
Matt Damon’s role as a CIA Assassin suffering
from amnesia singlehandedly re-defined modern
spy thrillers, showing Jason Bourne to possess
superhuman levels of stealth and battlefield
awareness.
When he first arrives on land after being
rescued from the sea by a fishing crew, he
quite literally disappears into the surrounding
city, illustrating how effective his innate
ability to remain undetected truly is.
Until viewers take a closer look at his disappearance,
and notice the pair of extras attempting – and
failing – to conceal actor Matt Damon ducking
behind the truck driving across the set, with
his feet and bright red jacket clearly visible.
Maybe another take would have been wise.
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
By the time the Chamber of Secrets rolled
around, Harry Potter and Draco Malfoy were
already each other’s worst enemies.
So it’s no surprise that when the children
of Hogwarts began their training in magical
duels, the two wound up crossing wands.
As always, Harry winds up getting the better
of his foe to the delight of the students
present.
The students, and the camera man who the director
either didn’t notice, or somehow assumed
audiences wouldn’t spot.
How this unplanned cameo wasn’t defeated
by some editing magic is beyond us.
Back to the Future
Aside from the questions of time travel and
parallel universes, Marty McFly’s trip backwards
and forwards through the decades is home to
several small mistakes or inconsistencies.
But it’s the most inconsequential error
that has become the most well-known – and
frankly, the most unsettling.
When Doc Brown returns with his family in
tow in the final scene of the trilogy, his
youngest son offers a gesture that once noticed,
can never be ignored.
Most accept that the young actor was simply
signaling that he was in need of a washroom
break, but we’re not buying it.
They don’t have toilets on time-traveling
trains?
Jurassic Park
The fact that Steven Spielberg’s dinosaur
adventure has aged better than most other
special effects-driven films is usually credited
to Steven Spielberg’s use of real dinosaur
models along with completely CGI creatures.
But that decision didn’t come without a
few drawbacks.
No fan will forget when a pair of raptors
pursued the movie’s child stars through
the park’s kitchen, but it turns out the
dinosaur models were less graceful than their
CG versions.
Apparently needing a crew member’s hand
to help keep their balance.
The Hurt Locker
It isn’t just dinosaurs that can use a hand
from an off-screen crew member.
In this story of a bomb disposal team deployed
during the Iraq War, soldiers on the ground
had more to worry about than just explosives.
When investigating an enemy-controlled warehouse,
someone on the film’s set decided that star
Jeremy Renner needed some help moving through
a curtain of plastic sheeting, putting his
entire hand into frame.
Why the shot wasn’t cut a moment sooner
is a mystery, meaning it’s entirely possible
it was missed altogether.
Gladiator
In a film as massive as Ridley Scott’s Roman
epic, audiences are willing to overlook some
small mistakes.
But the director put that theory to the test,
peppering the movie with too many mistakes
to count.
There’s the crew member who somehow stumbled
into a shot as hero Maximus greets a Roman
horse, Barbarian extras who decide to take
a break in the midst of a fierce battle, an
exposed air canister used to flip a chariot
in the Roman Coliseum, and the downright awful
body padding used to protect one actor from
arrows and swords.
But nothing beats star Russell Crowe’s famous
question, posed after he singlehandedly wiped
out multiple opponents.
It’s taken as a political statement for
those watching the fight, but it was clearly
directed at the camera crew visible in a wider
shot.
Jaws
When word first breaks of a man-eating shark
off the shores of Amity, everyone in possession
of a boat takes off in search of the bounty
placed on the great white’s head.
The chaos that follows is a nightmare for
Police Chief Brody, but is clearly perfect
for the filmmakers.
Apparently, director Steven Spielberg got
so captivated by the excitement, he assumed
audiences would be as well, leaving the entire
camera crew’s boats visible in the middle
of frame, revealing to audiences exactly how
they had captured the shots shown immediately
beforehand.
Raiders of the Lost Ark
Given the number of extras used in the first
Indiana Jones adventure, and how large some
of the movie’s action sequences were, a
mistake or unfortunate error is impossible
to avoid.
Take, for instance, the reflection of the
entire camera crew in the cockpit of a Nazi
aircraft, or the infamous ‘gun vs. sword’
sequence starring the world’s worst butcher.
But the film’s most ridiculous mistake is
also its most ironic.
To make sure their Tunisian backdrop resembled
1936 Cairo, the crew famously removed over
300 TV antennas from surrounding rooftops.
That level of dedication pays off in the finished
film... until a man wearing blue jeans and
a t-shirt strolls through the background just
minutes later.
The Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers
The second chapter of Peter Jackson’s fantasy
trilogy begins with three of the Fellowship
stumbling into the land of Rohan, leading
to a tense introduction with Eomer, a noble
soldier and ally in the rest of the story.
An embodiment of honour and dignity, Eomer
ends the standoff by giving his new allies
horses and sending them on their way.
Unfortunately, allowing his entire sword to
slide out of its sheath in the process.
Clearly too embarrassed to acknowledge the
mistake, we can only assume he left as quickly
as possible to find a suitable replacement.
Frozen
Just because animated films are created a
single frame at a time, that doesn’t mean
mistakes won’t slip by just as easily.
One of the most well-known sequences in Disney’s
smash success Frozen stars the magical Queen
Elsa, embracing her powers with a performance
of the award-winning song “Let it Go.”
In all the excitement, it seems the artists
decided to let the laws of physics go as well,
allowing Elsa to let down her hair, and have
it pass from front to back, phasing through
her left arm in the process.
The ability to control ice and snow and create
an eternal winter is one thing, but we have
to draw the line somewhere.
Those are some of our favourite movie mistakes
that seemed to slip by the filmmakers unnoticed.
Are there any we missed?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!